ballon et tire lire en main les élus du
conseil municipal des jeunes ont entamé
ce samedi une collecte de dons pour la
deuxième année consécutive dans le cadre
du sidaction les dons vont venir à
l'association achète prévention qui sont
pour les tests de dépistage rapide pour
les milieux défavorisés
parallèlement à cette collecte une
exposition se tient au pôle jeunesse
informations dépistage et traitement
mieux comprendre le sida pour mieux s'en
protéger alors qui a dit que les jeunes
ne prenait pas la prévention au sérieux
justement non pas le on en parle assez
et que les jeunes agissent beaucoup et
je pense que le problème vient beaucoup
des adultes qui pensent que justement le
préservatif c'est plus utile que les
tests de dépistage quand on n'est pas
atteint ou compte on pense ne pas être à
risque ils ne font pas et je pense que
vraiment la jeunesse on prend vraiment
conscience qui font les tests qui est
c'est vrai ça devient vraiment réflexe
ce week end 586 euros ont été récoltés